this is footage from a market in the
town of Horlick and the Donetsk region
of russian-controlled Ukraine it's one
of series of attacks carried out in the
past few days
yeah in the Russian city of veronese a
drone strikes an apartment building no
casualties were reported but the
regional government ordered a state of
emergency
there was a violent explosion I screamed
and the plumber who was fixing my drain
he saw it too he shouted it was a drone
and that was it that was the explosion
fast like lightning
Ukraine and Russia are trading
accusations over the shelling of
Rescuers and people being evacuated from
flooded regions in Carson
that's after the kakov kadam was
breached following an explosion on
Tuesday Russia blamed Ukrainian shelling
Ukraine says it and suscepted a phone
call proving Russia was responsible
Ukrainian forces have begun attacking
Russian defensive positions in recent
days
while Moscow says its forces repelled an
attack by Ukraine's Army and the
southern Dunya scanza peruja regions
Russia's President says Ukraine has
begun a counter-offensive
first of all we can definitely state
that this Ukrainian offensive has
started this is shown by the use of
strategic reserves that's the first
thing second the Ukrainian troops didn't
achieve their AIMS in any area of combat
that's absolutely obvious
there's no confirmation of that from the
Ukrainian side many believe kiev's next
move will likely be towards the
coastline to severe Russia's access to
Crimea
and for moscow's next move President
Vladimir Putin has announced his country
will start deploying tactical nuclear
weapons in Belarus from next month Ali
Hashem al-jazeera